[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien Ihnen allen einen
schönen guten Abend und Christian du
schaust später auf zwei knüllerpartien
in der Fußball Champions League Knüller
ist gut guten Abend hier ist unser
Angebot an diesem Dienstag
Solidarität mit Litauen
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius erneuert
das deutsche Beistand Versprechen des
baltische Land wünscht sich aber noch
mehr Bundeswehr Präsenz
nach den giftanschlägen auf Schulmädchen
in Iran gibt es erste Festnahmen und
neue Protestaktionen von Eltern und
Lehrern
auf den Kopf gestellt Werke von Georg
Baselitz treffen auf alte Meister zu
erleben im Kunsthistorischen Museum in
Wien
[Musik]
unsere Sicherheit wird auch am
Hindukusch verteidigt so
Verteidigungsminister Struck vor vielen
Jahren über die Stationierung deutscher
Soldaten in Afghanistan heute wählte
seinen spd-nachfolger Pistorius ähnliche
Worte um die Wichtigkeit der von
Deutschland angeführten NATO-Mission in
Litauen zu verdeutlichen er sagte die
Sicherheit Litauens sei auch unsere
Sicherheit
innerhalb der nato-ostflanke ist Litauen
in einer besonderen Situation das Land
grenzt zum einen an die russische
Exklave Kaliningrad und zum anderen an
den Moskau Verbündeten Belarus rund 800
deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind
ständig dort etwa 600 nehmen jetzt
zusätzlich an einer Militärübung Teil
die Regierung in Vilnius hätte aber
dauerhaft gerne mehr aus Litauen Ines
Trams
weit sind Sie gereist die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten der Panzer grenadierbrigade
Vorpommern um hier die Abwehr eines
möglichen russischen Angriffs zu üben es
gilt Litauen zur Seite zu springen
Verteidigungsbereitschaft will man
zeigen abschrecken und für den Fall der
Fälle vorbereitet sein
man muss sich kennen man muss
miteinander üben man muss zu man muss
zusammenwachsen die einsatzverfahren
voneinander kennen und nur so kann das
am Ende des Tages klappen seine erste
Reise zu einem Auslandseinsatz führt
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hierher
an die Ostflanke nach dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine verstärkte die NATO den
Schutz für Litauen Deutschland sagte
eine Brigade zu Pistorius signalisiert
Unterstützung ohne Wenn und Aber
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
Ostflanke wie unsere Sicherheit wurde
gewährleistet durch die Nato und ihre
Verbündeten und heute ist eben Polen das
Baltikum und andere Länder die Ostflanke
und deswegen sind wir heute genauso in
der Verpflichtung diesen Schutz zu
gewährleisten wie das die NATO damals
für uns
getanus und Berlin historius Amtskollege
fordert dass die zugesagte Brigade mit
bis zu 5000 Männern und Frauen dauerhaft
hier stationiert wird und nicht nur zum
Üben kommt historius hadert mit einer
festen Präsenz doch für den Litauer
beginnt die NATO Verteidigungslinie
genau hier
die geografische Lage der baltischen
Staaten erfordert eine stärkere Präsenz
der Bündnispartner in der Region um eine
zuverlässige Abschreckung und vorne
Verteidigung zu gewährleisten was ist
militärisch und von der Abschreckung und
von der Flexibilität der das richtige
eine feste Brigade im Baltikum oder
mehrere oder ist es besser zum Schutz
der gesamten Ostflanke über flexible
Einheiten nachzudenken die Entscheidung
über eine dauerhafte Stationierung in
Litauen sie ist zunächst vertagt bis zum
NATO-Gipfel im Sommer hier in Vilnius
jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine und zu
den Gefechten in der Stadt bachmut im
Osten des Landes ja jetzt schon Monate
andauern dort hat sich ein
zermürbungskampf entwickelt Russen wie
Ukraine haben in bachmut hohe Verluste
die vielen Verwundeten zu versorgen ist
für die Sanitäter eine Herkulesarbeit
wie ein ukrainisches
freiwilligenbataillon mit einem
umgebauten Bus
Opfer in Sicherheit bringt das zeigt uns
unsere Reporter Henna
er sieht aus wie ein ganz normaler
Reisebus tatsächlich rettet erleben
ausgestattet mit medizinischen Geräten
bringt der verwundete Kämpfer ins
sichere Hinterland
die meisten haben verletzte Gliedmaßen
Schuss oder splitterwunden oft gibt es
Leute mit lungenverletzungen wenn der
Brustkorb getroffen wurde das erleben
wir hier sehr oft Danilo und andere
Ärzte und Sanitäter der
Hilfsorganisation Hospital wollen so
viele Leben retten wie möglich es ist
ein Städter Wettlauf mit der Zeit denn
von der Front in bachmut kommen ständig
neue Opfer für die Ukraine ist eine
Aufgabe der Stadt aktuell keine Option
nördlich von wachmut falsche Jäger und
Panzer brigaten und Artillerie
zusammengezogen aus leichter und
schwerer Artillerie werden dort 250 bis
300 Geschosse am Tag auf uns abgefeuert
selbst in Lebensgefahr ziehen
Rettungskurs auf dem Schlachtfeld
Verwundete der Schusslinie und bringen
Sie zur medizinischen Erstversorgung
Bilder aus den bodycams zweier deutscher
Helfer lassen das Grauen erahnen später
im evakuierungskurs ist für ihn der
Krieg erstmal vorbei
eine Drohne hat eine Granate auf mich
abgeworfen mein Knie ist kaputt ein
Finger gebrochen das war heute Nacht
die Helfer von Hospital haben ihn ins
Krankenhaus gebracht sie werden auch
heute wieder Verletzte in Sicherheit
bringen
blicken wir auf eine rätselhafte
vergiftungswelle in den letzten Monaten
sollen im Iran bis zu 5000 Schülerinnen
vergiftet worden sein für Eltern ein
Albtraum sie protestierten auch heute
wieder zahlreich für mehr Sicherheit
jetzt oder besser erst jetzt sind in
fünf Provinzen Verdächtige verhaftet
worden Jörg Brase berichtet
verurteilt die sich Chemie Angriffe
rufen Lehrer und Eltern in Karat
Proteste auch in anderen Städten im Land
die Wut wächst auf untätige Behörden im
provinz-krankenhaus waren die waren da
Reh waren am Wochenende erst wieder
Kinder mit Vergiftungen eingeliefert
worden
als niemand zum Sportunterricht kam sind
wir in die Eingangshalle gelaufen und
der roch es so komisch wie nach Parfums
mein ganzer Körper war taub ich konnte
nicht mehr laufen
mehrere tausend zumeist Schülerinnen
wurden seit November offenbar mit einem
Gas vergiftet erst jetzt nach über drei
Monaten meldet sich Irans oberster
Führer Eier toller Name zu Wort und
fordert die Täter zu finden und hart zu
bestrafen
denn das ist keine Kleinigkeit es sind
Verbrechen gegen die schwächsten gegen
unschuldige Kinder Verbrechen die Angst
und Unsicherheit der Gesellschaft und
den betroffenen Familien verbreiten
wer hinter den mysteriösen Anschlägen
steckt ist noch völlig unklar
es handelt sich offenbar um chemische
Angriffe die Behörden haben die Vorfälle
bislang völlig unterschätzt und es gab
offenbar bisher auch kein großes
Interesse daran diese Angriffe
aufzuklären
nach dem Machtwort des Staatsoberhaupts
meldeten die Behörden heute erste
Festnahmen von Tatverdächtigen vorher
aber war ein Journalist festgesetzt
worden der zu den Vorfällen
recherchierte und Eltern die für die
Sicherheit ihrer Kinder demonstriert
werden
über den Flughafen im syrischen Aleppo
gelangen Hills Lieferungen mehrerer
Länder zu den Erdbeben Opfern jetzt ist
der Airport nach syrischen Angaben
geschlossen weil Israel ihn angegriffen
haben soll Israel kommentierte die
Berichte nicht bombardiert aber
regelmäßig Ziele im Bürgerkriegsland
Syrien und damit um damit den
waffennachschub für Iran Treue Milizen
zu verhindern
in Frankreich dagegen heute fast nichts
mehr Züge Flughäfen Schulen Müllabfuhr
sie alle streikten gegen die geplante
Rentenreform das Land nahezu lahmgelegt
die größte Protestaktion seit
Jahrzehnten treibt Menschenmassen auf
die Straßen während der Senat die Pläne
von Präsident macron berät
[Musik]
wächst und der Protest wird immer lauter
auf Frankreich Straßen alle
Altersgruppen demonstrieren Branchen
übergreifend rund 70% der Französinnen
und Franzosen lehnen die Rentenreform
vehement ab sie finden sie ungerecht
jeder hat die Nase voll von diesen
Ungleichheiten zwischen Arm und Reich
die durch die Rentenreform noch
verschärft werden
im Senat laufen seit Wochen die
Diskussionen das Renteneintrittsalter
soll mit der Reform auf 64 Jahre
angehoben werden vor allem um die Renten
verlässlich finanzieren zu können von
bei 20 Millionen Menschen
und das ohne auch nur einen Euro der
Kaufkraft einzubüßen die Steuern zu
erhöhen oder die Renten zu kürzen das
bedeutet dass wir alle ein bisschen
länger arbeiten müssen
konkret 43 Arbeitsjahre für den Erhalt
der vollen Rente ohne uns sagen die
Gewerkschaften schon in der Nacht
brannten die ersten Straßen Barrikaden
Züge und Metro fahren nur vereinzelt
Flüge sind gestrichen und alle
Raffinerien im Land blockiert Präsident
macron will trotz aller Proteste an
seiner großen Reform festhalten und
hofft auf Zustimmung im Parlament auf
der Straße fühlen sich viele ungehört
und wollen nicht dass über ihren Kopf
hinweg entschieden wird
jetzt zu einer heikel in Frage die das
Deutsch chinesische Verhältnis weiter
belasten könnte gefährdet chinesische
Mobilfunktechnik die im deutschen
Handynetz eingebaut wurde die nationale
Sicherheit möglicherweise schon diesen
Schluss lässt zumindest ein Schreiben zu
dass das Innenministerium an alle
Netzbetreiber verschickte jetzt soll
eine umfangreiche Überprüfung kommen und
neben der Sicherheit steht jetzt auch
die Kostenfrage im Raum Volker
Deutschlands
Telekommunikationsunternehmen bekommen
unerwartete Mehrarbeit die Nachkontrolle
des 5g-netzes die Branche sollen noch
einmal bereits verarbeitete
Steuerelemente der chinesischen
Unternehmen Huawei und ZTE unter die
Lupe nehmen dahinter steckt offenbar die
Sorge vor Spionage und Sabotage das
Bundesinnenministerium spricht offiziell
nur von Risiken
und da geht es insbesondere um
missbrauchsrisiken was die Sicherheit
die Vertraulichkeit die Integrität die
Verfügbarkeit oder Funktionsfähigkeit
dieser kritischen
telekommunikationsinfrastrukturen angeht
dass sich Deutschland mit China anlegt
viele Jahre und denkbar die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen hatten immer
Priorität
Oppositionspolitiker wollen auch Lehren
aus den gescheiterten deutsch-russischen
Beziehungen ziehen sie fordern ein
Umdenken und mehr Kontrolle wer die
Netze beherrscht wer dieses 5g
beherrscht der hat enormen Einfluss in
Deutschland und diese Souveränität
dürfen wir nicht an ein Unternehmen
ausliefern das dem Einfluss eines
autoritären diktatorischen Staates
seinerseits ausgeliefert ist
aber Kontrolle kostet Geld
wahrscheinlich viel Geld und das will
der Branchenverband auf keinen Fall
allein bezahlen die Netzbetreiber haben
absolut gesetzeskonform und
sicherheitsüberprüft mit Brief und Segel
Technologien eingekauft und verbaut und
wenn jetzt die Politik im Nachhinein zu
anderen Schlussfolgerungen kommt die sie
ihre damaligen Entscheidungen revidieren
lässt da muss ja auch die Kosten dafür
übernehmen und es wird wahrscheinlich
noch teurer denn die Bundesregierung
will auch die 4G-Technologie auf
Sicherheitsrisiken untersuchen lassen
frauen verdienen immer noch weniger Geld
als Männer und daran erinnert heute der
Equal Pay Day er markiert symbolisch den
Tag im Jahr bis zu dem Frauen umsonst
arbeiten während Männer vom ersten
Januar abbezahlt werden in Prozenten
gesagt Frauen bekommen 18 % weniger auch
weil sie eher in Teilzeit arbeiten und
klassische Frauenberufe weniger Geld
bringen das alles rausgerechnet bleiben
aber immer noch rund sieben Prozent
Benachteiligung Davids machen
Haare schneiden Kinder erziehen alte
pflegen Frauen arbeiten häufiger als
Männer in Branchen mit niedrigem
Einkommen noch dazu sind deutlich mehr
Frauen in teilzeitbeschäftigt als Männer
für die Aufsichtsrätin und erfahrene
spitzenmanagerin Simone Menne ist das
eine unterschätzte Gefahr wenn Frauen
ihr Leben lang Teilzeit arbeiten in
dieser teilzeitfalle sind weil es
teilweise wegen ehegattenspielen
finanziell vermeintlich okay ist weil
sie am Ende als Paar dasselbe
rauskriegen sie haben dann als Frau aber
am Ende viel weniger Rente doch das
Lohngefälle besteht nicht nur zwischen
sondern auch innerhalb der Berufsgruppen
ein Beispiel Ärztin verdienen in
Vollzeit im Schnitt 30% weniger als
Ärzte können Frauen nicht richtig
verhandeln das Max-Planck-Institut in
Bonn hat in Labor versuchen
herausgefunden Frauen scheuen
tatsächlich Wettbewerbs und
Risikosituation es ist ja so dass wir in
unserer Wirtschaftsform
fällt kaum einem jemand der Job einfach
so vom Himmel auf die Schultern herunter
sondern man muss tatsächlich den Hut in
den Ring werfen sich mit anderen messen
sich bewerben mit unsicherem Ausgang was
die Forschenden am Max-Planck-Institut
auch festgestellt haben
Quotenregelungen motivieren Frauen zum
Wettbewerb und zwar insbesondere die
leistungsstarken Frauen heißt das ganze
blöde stammtischgeräte von unter
qualifizierten Quoten Frauen sollte man
valentieres vergessen ja bei den
Bildungsabschlüssen haben Frauen
gegenüber Männern übrigens die Nase vorn
beim Einkommen gibt es noch einiges
aufzuholen
und die ganze Dokumentation unserer
Kollegen können Sie heute Abend in
Dreisatz sehen um 22 Uhr 26 und schon
jetzt finden Sie das Video in der ZDF
heute App dort auch weitere Infos zum
Equal Pay Day
sie haben es vielleicht bemerkt wenn Sie
heute tagsüber Fernsehen geschaut haben
einige unserer heute und Magazin
Sendungen sind ausgefallen grund war ein
Warnstreik das ZDF und die
Gewerkschaften fahrenden gerade über
einen neuen Tarifvertrag
zum ersten Mal sind zwei klimaaktivisten
der Gruppe letzte Generation zu
Haftstrafen ohne Bewährung verurteilt
worden die Männer sollen für zwei
beziehungsweise drei Monate ins
Gefängnis zusammen mit anderen
Demonstranten hatten sie sich Anfang
Februar auf einer Straße in Heilbronn
festgeklebt vorher schon bei ähnlichen
Aktionen aufgefallen erklärten sie vor
Gericht weitermachen zu wollen darum
dass ungewohnt harte Urteil das aber
noch angefochten werden kann
Georg Baselitz ist einer der
erfolgreichsten deutschen Künstler
unserer Zeit Sammler Zahlen Millionen
für seine Bilder Provokation gehört ja
zum Kerngeschäft der Kunst aber die Art
und Weise wie Baselitz sie betrieb blieb
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes hängen viel
Sex und viel verkehrt herum das
Kunsthistorische Museum Wien zeigt von
heute an seine von ihm mitgestaltete
Ausstellung zu sehen seine nackten und
die alte Meister Britta Hilpert
kunsthistorisch ist Nacktheit nichts
Neues neu ist die Kombi
auch für Baselitz selbst ich bin in
meinem Zweifel aber wenn ich das sehe
muss irgendwie was richtig gemacht
worden sein
die Ausstellung
nackte Meister bringt neue Blicke auf
altes
[Musik]
was werden diese alten Meister sagen
wenn heute so frisches Blut in diese
Räume kommt ja wie werden sich die
verstehen jetzt ja
herrliche Party heute
fünf Säle mit meistern wie Cranach
memeling und fast fünf Jahrzehnten
Baselitz so viel modern war nie im
Kunsthistorischen Museum
Baselitz malt über Kopf befreit und
schwerelos für dachpino heißt über Kopf
engelssturz zwischen Himmel und Erde ist
der Mensch wo ist Baselitz er ist im
Olymp und er ist aufgenommen in die
Riege der alten aber Meister ich weiß
gar nicht ob er das möchte dass ein
alter Meister ist möchte das eben nicht
Bodenhaftung und Humor hat Baselitz er
hat bestimmt was zusammen hängt
ob es auch zusammen gehört darf jeder
selbst entscheiden
[Musik]
ja Fußballfans die stehen vielleicht
auch Kopf weil zwei knüllerpartien in
der Fußball Champions League anstehen
oder top das ist das Motto borussia
Dortmund hat das erste der vier
deutschen Mannschaften die Chance ins
Viertelfinale einzuziehen heute abend
auswärts beim FC Chelsea im Gepäck das
1:0 aus dem Hinspiel und ein richtig
guten Lauf
der BVB strotzt vor Selbstvertrauen hat
als einziges Team in Europas top liegen
alle Pflichtspiele 2023 gewonnen und
zuletzt auch die engen Begegnungen für
sich entschieden exemplarisch dafür der
Sieg gegen Leipzig vergangenen Freitag
doch Trainer ihr den tersit Schmarn vor
dem Champions League Rückspiel beim
Tabellen 10 der Premier League zur
Vorsicht wir haben gesehen welches
Potenzial diese Mannschaft hat ich
glaube auch nicht dass der Tabellenstand
dem entspricht was sie aktuell leisten
sie haben da auch wirklich in den
letzten Wochen nicht die Punkte
eingefahren diese eigentlich verdient
gehabt hätten der Form starke Dortmunder
Schlussmann Gregor Kobel nach muskulären
Problemen fraglich Karim adejemi
Torschütze beim 1:0 hinspieler Erfolg
fällt hingegen definitiv aus die
Ausgangslage für schwarz gelb gut aber
nicht komfortabel
ja und für die Bayern wäre morgen Abend
ein Sieg gegen PSG die perfekte Antwort
auf die aktuelle sportliche Kritik
immerhin der einzelnen Hinspielerfolg
ist schon mal eine Bank die Fans im
Rücken alle Spieler fit die Ausgangslage
bei den Bayern stimmt Paris ohne den
verletzten Neymar aber mit Messi und vor
allem Emma P
er ist einfach einer der besten Stürmer
der Welt mit unglaublichen Waffen die
hat morgen spielt davon Beginn an sprich
wir können uns von Beginner auch darauf
einstellen
du wirst trotzdem nicht immer alles
verteidigen können weil einfach
außergewöhnliche Fähigkeiten hat ihn
stoppen soll Jose sitzt dajic als Ersatz
für den Papa und nagelsmann der träumt
auf der PK schon von mehr der Triumph in
der Königsklasse sein größter Wunsch
doch erst einmal gilt es PSG
auszuschalten
auf der Königsetappe des oceanways hat
sich Boris Hermann mit seiner Crew auf
Rang 3 vorgekämpft die größeren Probleme
an der Yacht malizia konnten behoben
werden und man könne endlich wieder zu
100% Segeln allerdings bleibt die
Wetterlage im südlichen Ozean arg
knifflig also mir wird schon komisch und
ein bisschen seekrank ist auch nichts
für aber Wetter ist ein gutes Stichwort
danke Christin fünf bis 20 cm Neuschnee
sind heute Nacht möglich wo genau das
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja vorne
mit Christian Siebers vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen noch einen entspannten Abend
für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend das stürmische tief
kornelies ist heute von der Nordsee
weiter nach Südschweden gezogen es
trennt kalte Luft aus Norden von
milderer Luft im Süden dieses Wolkenband
markiert nicht nur eine kalt von sondern
eine Luftmassengrenze und an der fällt
heute Nacht viel Schnee 5 bis 10 in der
Eifel sogar 20 cm Neuschnee das wird den
Verkehr behindern einzelne Schneeschauer
gibt es auch in Schleswig-Holstein die
Temperaturen sinken heute Nacht auf +3
bis -4 Grad und liegen morgen im Norden
bei drei bis fünf Grad im Süden wird es
dagegen sehr mild mit 9 bis 13 Grad in
der Mitte aber hier von Sachsen über
Thüringen und Hessen bis nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen Rheinland-Pfalz
liegen die Höchstwerte nur so bei 0 bis
3 Grad das ist genau der Bereich in dem
sie sich besonders morgen Früh und am
Vormittag auf weitere Schneefälle und
Glätte einstellen müssen im Laufe des
Tages steigt die Schneefallgrenze an im
Süden fällt kräftiger Regen und im
Norden sehen sie häufiger die Sonne es
ist ganz freundlich mit einigen Schnee
schauen der Donnerstag wird ruhiger
Freitag und Samstag schüttet es dann im
Westen und dem Süden Energie nicht und
dazu wird das auch wieder deutlich
weniger guten Abend